welcome to in context i am david
bachman and here in the usa we are
getting closer to the third peak of
the covid 19 coronavirus the first peak
of course in april the second at the end
of july and now getting closer and closer
to the third peak a bit later today in  the
program we will talk about the importance of
that but first we are going to talk to the
mayor of the city of los angeles of the
state of california
eric garcetti well mayor it is a pleasure to
speak with you to begin with and many
many early and absentee votes this
election and of course  We have to be
careful with the inferences we make
based on the coronavirus situation, but
as you see the situation in California
with early voting, absentee voting, there were
some problems with fake vote boxes
that the Republicans put up with
how everything is being handled in Los Angeles, well,
I'm  successful to see this
voter enthusiasm not only in
california and los angeles but
everywhere in the usa we
need to  We need all the votes of the
residents of the united states during
this critical election but if there are a lot of
people there are many parties the super
tucanos here in california that are
gambling with our votes and it is
important to protect the right of
all citizens to vote in the  elections
not only for the president but it is
important because there are local measures
there are state representatives to people
who are in these elections and we
need to protect this the animals
we have
safe in front of all the
libraries for example but there are four
times more early votes now and this
It is a population of d
at this time and the crisis not only
of Kobe but of the crisis of our
democracy I hope that this election is
and finally they can write a new
chapter in the history not only of
the USA but for me here in Los
Angeles and California  also if from the
point of view of the importance of
Latino voters and the Latino people and  or
I don't remember such an
important election specifically seeing how
the Latino vote is going to end up the
Latino people in general a people from the
left in the US vote for Democrats
in the particular exception it tends to
be Cuban-Americans who are from the
Latino people  The more right-wing spoke with
the congresswoman and we already saw
jail last week and she said that the
Cuban-American community is still not
particularly happy with the
president and
is partly planning to throw him out to Iovine in
Los Angeles and in California. How do they see the
different communities?
Hispanics and we have a
very diverse Latino community from many countries many
generations and many perspectives but
in the campaign like him as president
shrugs off asking for the Joplin campaign
we have the support of all the different
Latino communities
including the Cuban community but the
Boricua community the communities of
Central America, Mexican Americans and
South America have special messages.  Specific
in English and Spanish these communities
of the record of Giovanni the heart and the
story of Giovanni Cámara bosses as
a daughter of immigrants
remember the words
of pain trump are very important to
remember for example he has insulted
our communities our culture the
mexicans  americans like criminals and
we are very practical practical
we have a perspective where we
want to know a leader not just an
instrument like a samper a person who
can bring results that improve
our lives
iovine is this type of leader as let
times this type of release and it is
It is important to have this contrast and to
remember the insults of corruption
when we vote in this election.
If in the last two or three weeks
at rallies the president frequently
says these prepared phrases I
love Hispanic people in English he says the
phoenix it
is because he is  doing that I think
the president is out of desperation
r  He recognizes what the Hispanic people need
to gain an echo, how he sees it,
we are winning the
Latino vote in the vanilla campaign now and the
airs of the people who do not
need to decide the route from their
two-for-one vote for trump are
seeing  to the campaign d
de baile y xerez and this is a reflection
of our values ​​we have a lot of
confidence in the Latino community when we
return to the pal partido latino where
we are in the donation administration
if he said the spy next the dnic where
we are in the walker  in the
positions of power
this is just words but the
actions
the platform of the democrats is
specifically to improve the situation
with kobe 19 to reform and rebuild
our economy and save our lives
in those aspects of climate change
in california with the fires in the
south with the hurricanes it is important to
attend not only words but
also plans this contrast is very very
strong in the next segment speaks  Let's go
a little more specifically about what
you would like to see from the point of
view of cobi 19 follow iovine but
outside of that issue from the economic point of
view which is what
you think would be the first priority of
an iovine presidency
specifically for the people of los
angeles and california we need to
speed up the economy and provide more
jobs especially for the
latino community of immigrant community but
all of us in the usa we need more money
more resources in infrastructure these
jobs are middle class jobs
we have the  opportunity to bring
workers with the skills into
our community colleges
to prosper for the next
generation
and Latinos especially, we are one
of the largest and largest American workforce
of workers in
this country and our plans are very
specific to transform the
energy sector clean and green energy
invest in the ca  lles these
highways in for internet access for
our students and our businesses
is very specific and is a plan for the
prosperity of the next generation for
two or three decades not only to
restore the situation during this
crisis but a very broad vision
throughout the  country
we will take a brief break and continue in
moments with the mayor of los angeles and
resources teri we now continue the
conversation with the mayor of los
angeles california erc carter and also
with head of the national campaign of the
democratic candidate for the presidency
iovine mayor with the topic  of cob and 19
we are approaching a third peak
nationally peak number one was in
april peak number two was at the end of july
and the numbers are going up again
the vaccine is not known when it will be
available it is not known how effective it
will be and how do you see  the next
six months regarding kobe 19 and
what could be a president of
iovine immediately in january if
p  irst it is important to remember that this
investigation has been a failure
with kobe 19 we have 220 thousand deaths there is
no plan the administration does not have
the government between the
local state and federal levels of government
shopping
will bring a specific plan for our
schools for health to  get to
all the needs of our
hospitals our medical staff and
also to have a plan where
science doctors are important again
during the round to their opinions to their
their political needs are more
important than words and reviewed the
advice of our doctors  and it is very
important in a country where we have
only 4 percent of the
world's population but we have more than 20
percent of the deaths to finally
restore the need for
universal actions with masks with a
sanz distance to wash hands
these  things there is no leadership in the
white house there are different words galleries
in messages  different every week and
finally with giovanni like during the
iv ball when he was vice president it
will be a coronation it will be a plan and it will be at a
level of unity in all parts of this
country during this administration the
west is you are suffering and then
from the east the north the  midwest
and then south we
need leadership across the country
anyway and iovine will be a
president across the country talking about
national leadership
you would like to have a
national mask mandate that would indeed
not be a national mandate would be a
recommendation
governors who  make
state mandates but you think it is a
good idea yes it is a good idea but
unfortunately power exists
only in the hands of the states and
I hope with a leader like Gióvine he
can bring all the collectors to the
white house and work with them to
obtain this mandate in all
states
unfortunately
this president presents nou has the
interest d  e this book
he wants to imagine that this virus one day
you disappeared but no no that is the
situation in the situations of this it is
important to have the trait and standard
are louis the same everywhere in
this country in all states because
the borders between our  The states are
artificial and the virus can travel
between two states in one day, so it is
important to stop this attitude with regard to
the issue of vaccines. Do you know something
you can tell us about the
president said that by October
we would have an approved vaccine the  from the
cdc and other organizations say it will
take more time from the point of
view as an administrator and you from the
city of angels that is what the
public health experts are
telling you
well we are preparing for a vaccine
and a vaccine is  critical but
dangerous vaccines without the notice of the scientific community
there is a war against science and the
scientists of the night but here the
angles  What we are preparing for the
distribution of this is important
, the influenza vaccine is now very
important too,
but due to Kobe 19 there are many candidates
for a vaccine, but
we must have a safe vaccine, and when
we have this official notice from the
doctors, not the politicians, we
can  give this vaccine to all the
presidents of los angeles and when
we have this one we will finally have an
open economy but this is an
aspect of his election by trump it is not
an aspect of our health we were
talking to the mayor of the city
of angels from the state of  california y
recursos teri it's a lot of pleasure and we
appreciate your time it's always a
pleasure thank you